[Music]
why can't you say Voldemort what happens
if you say Voldemort out loud in Harry
Potter
almost right from the beginning it is
expressed at saying Voldemort's name out
loud is a big faux pas but this is never
quite properly explained I mean I guess
I can kind of understand why people
wouldn't want to say or hear it given
that he is perhaps the most destructive
Dark Wizard of all time and ruin many
many lives but what happens exactly if
you do say it in this video I'm going to
bust this question wide open and give
you my take on this topic we first
noticed this happening right at the very
beginning of the series in the
Philosopher's Stone people seem to be
saying you know who instead of Voldemort
but why some have theorized that the
practice of saying you know who in place
of Voldemort began during the first
Wizarding War likely because whenever
people would say it Death Eaters
Voldemort and destruction would find
them however I don't think this theory
is correct my reason for that being that
Dumbledore has always been an advocate
of saying Voldemort's name freely so
that fear is taken away from the name
itself I don't think the Dumbledore
would have encouraged people to put
their lives in danger if he didn't feel
that it would be safe to do so
however this only applies to the first
Wizarding war the answer to Voldemort's
name phenomenon is of course the result
of the taboo curse which is a spell that
designates a word as a key to revealing
the speaker's location it is speculated
that Voldemort placed the taboo curse on
his name sometime in 1997 this meant
that whenever his name was uttered it
would alert Death Eaters and Snatchers
to the location of the speaker as the
only people who dared to say Voldemort's
name were members of the order of the
Phoenix this made finding their enemies
very easy a good example of the taboo
curse in action is in the last book when
the trio are camping and harry says
Voldemort's name out loud this causes
them to get caught by the Snatchers
where they are taken to Malfoy Manor if
Harry had never said Voldemort's name
then perhaps they would have never found
the last of the Horcruxes I expected
they would been wandering around for a
fair bit other known examples of the
taboo being triggered
Hermione said his name on Tottenham
Court Road and when Kingsley said it
which led to the ordered the phoenixes
awareness of the taboos existence
whether or not certain defensive spells
work against the taboo curse is unknown
though there is some speculation that
lower-level defensive enchantments like
invisibility won't work and higher level
defensive spells like the fidelia's
charm will work the fidelia's charm
explanation is supported by the fact
that the trio were protected at number
12 per Mille place in spite of saying
his name however one thing to bear in
mind is that the fidelia's charm is
particularly powerful and difficult to
cast so it may be the strongest
protection available against the taboo
curse that's it for the video if you
guys have more questions on this topic
or have any video ideas that you'd like
myself and star wars theory to cover
please comment them down below until
next time hurry hurry
did you put on able to cobble to fire
Dumbledore asked calmly
[Music]